i'm definitely not going to do a proper
intro for this because i want to keep it
short
it's been a while but if you guys have
been keeping up with the channel then
you know that i've run into some
copyright issues
i of course reached out to the company
making the claims as well as youtube and
was shocked to find that nobody cares to
be fair i'm a pretty small blip on the
radar so this played out
basically exactly how i thought it would
it was a matter of time guys somebody
had to come in and put a stop to my
menacing ways i was costing these
companies tens and tens of dollars
but whatever it's fine they have every
right to do what they did so i guess i
can't really hold it against them it's
more of a can they be mad versus a
should they be that kind of argument and
i don't think anybody cares enough to
have that argument so instead i'm just
gonna stay away from katakana corpse
anime and hopefully that'll fix that
since i was gonna be on hiatus anyways
while i got all of this stuff sorted i
figured i might as well go through and
update my graphics and logos and all
that fun stuff for the new year so
hopefully that turns out okay also
i've also been entertaining the idea of
branching into some new video formats
but don't freak out don't be like oh my
gosh
this is recap journal this is why it's
up to you i'm still doing recap videos i
like doing recap videos gonna get did
you doing recap videos the only
difference is that i'm gonna be doing
three videos instead of one for each
season that i cover
of course this includes a full recap
video like the ones i've been doing up
until this point but on top of that i'm
also going to be doing a what to know
series
which is just gonna be basically
covering the essential information so
you don't get bogged down with all the
filler content that comes with the full
recap
and round it all together i want to make
a review video for each season talking
about what makes it good what makes it
bad how it compares to the previous
seasons and ultimately should you even
bother watching it because i have spent
a lot of time watching anime and was
like yep that was a huge waste of time
so ideally i can save you from wasting
as much time as i did plus if i keep on
running into copyright issues this will
give me a place to pivot to so the
channel doesn't just die if i'm not
doing recap videos not to mention i
start running out of new shows to cover
before they come out and originally i
was going to start branching into older
longer shows i
eat your one piece or full metal
alchemists like the classics but i'm not
sure how many people would be interested
in watching those kind of videos in this
format because there would just be so
much information and on top of that it
would take me so long to do it so if
nobody watches the videos then it just
wouldn't be worth the massive time
investment now i need you guys to know
that i get it okay i understand how
cliche it is for the youtuber to come on
and be like hey what are you guys
thinking
throw it in the comments but in reality
they don't give a [ __ ] about your
opinion they just want the comments for
the algorithms which is fine but that's
not what this
is says in some sort of weird meta
youtube [ __ ] i actually want to hear
what you guys are thinking because
realistically you're my only source of
feedback so if you have any requests
or suggestions please tell me you don't
have to put in the comments although you
could
i mean i'm not saying it's a bad thing
to put in the comments just know that if
you get the information to me i will
read it actually for the longest time i
was thinking about just doing a video
series
of reading and responding to comments so
maybe i'll just do that instead put
hashtag attention [ __ ] at the bottom of
your comment
and you could be included in the next
video or maybe not he [ __ ] knows i'll
try my best to utilize and integrate
whatever feedback you guys have but you
know just
be civil about it don't come on here but
oh my gosh i hate your voices like what
do you want me to do with information
what am i supposed to do with the
information you hate my voice you want
me to talk differently
because you have a specific preference
in male tone and because i don't match
that preference you want to tell me
about it's like [ __ ] man
my bad let me do that for you
anyways as far as the last hiatus goes i
was planning on being back in like a
week or two but that turned into a
couple of months because my
income took a pretty big hit thanks to
the copyright issues which took down
all of my top videos so i had to refocus
on doing freelance work and other side
projects to keep my head above water but
now that i have some more time
and wiggle room i can start paying more
attention to the channel and rethinking
how i'm doing things which is where all
of this is coming from
platform updates realistically this is
all stuff i've been procrastinating
doing but i have been trying to branch
into other avenues for you guys
i'm not super into social media because
i don't think i'm that interesting to
people so technically yes i have a
twitter gonna be honest i'm not even
sure what i'm supposed to be doing with
that [ __ ] just throw my two cents in on
random stuff i don't know i'll try and
be more active on these things but i
also made a new discord
no idea if you guys are gonna use it but
there was a couple of different requests
so one tutorial video later boom new
discord
can't promise that'll be that active on
there but if you guys want to chat
have questions hit me up pretty much
anywhere just you know don't be weird or
rude or whatever just be normal and i'll
be normal we can get along i also
thought about making a new reddit but i
don't know how
active that would be honestly i just
kind of want one so you guys can go and
post a bunch of memes and i can react to
them it's free content but you know
maybe someday dream big
now we get to the sellout segment oh are
you broke or something
yeah pretty much also i [ __ ] your mom
if you want to skip this segment you can
jump ahead to this time stamp and i'll
see you there
i try not to sell out on this channel
because this is weird and it makes me
uncomfortable and i'm not very good at
it but i have had a patreon for a while
now and i don't really know what to do
with it because there are people on
there who are supporting me and no
they're not my relatives no
i don't know them or anything so that's
even more crazy to me but i want to put
together a tier list of stuff that's
actually worthwhile because everything
on patreon is just like
yeah you technically you get this but
it's like no you're just giving me money
like
yeah you get this but it's like who
cares that's worth nothing so if you
have any ideas on what you want to see
offered in the tier list then let me
know
and i will definitely look into that i
also want to get merch going which i'll
probably just do through teespring so if
you guys want to support the channel you
can at least get
a t-shirt or a hat you know something
tangible out of it instead of just
giving me money and i think that would
be way better
and if not it's fine i'm doing fine
gonna be making videos either way
i just appreciate you guys paying
attention to a smaller channel so don't
feel obligated but it is there
i mean technically it is available to
you
right now it is so
no okay well you know it's not a big
deal i still appreciate you guys it's
all good
you guys can probably just ignore this
next part
well well look who jumped ahead to this
time stamp to skip over the sell out
segment isn't that nice how brave of you
well
you know what fun fact there was no
sellout segment i was giving away free
stuff and you missed out so eat your
heart out and also here why don't you
jump ahead to this time stamp
get the [ __ ] out so typically this is
where you're supposed to put an outro
that really ties the video together
and makes the viewer reflect on like
[ __ ] that was a good video i'm not gonna
do any of that [ __ ] because
the reality is nobody ever watches the
outro that's why i hate doing outros and
intros who the [ __ ] cares about the
outro and the intro it's never
filled with content or useful
information it's just garbage
so i usually cut it out but the catch is
i need people to get baited by my time
stamp
so i can't just have it end i need to
like keep monologuing
so that they think there's more to the
video and then they're gonna click my
time step and get roasted by me and then
they're just gonna be caught in this
endless loop of hell
of just me talking and if you think that
there's something coming at the end of
the video
i'm sorry you've come too far to be
disappointed and i'm still going to
disappoint you
there's nothing coming at the end of the
video so if you just see yourself
out it doesn't have to be awkward
doesn't have to be weird you can just
leave i'm not going to judge you
i hope you have a nice day at this point
if you're still watching the video
that i don't know how i can explain it
to you differently
that there's nothing coming at the end
of the video i don't do outros because
nobody says to the end of the video and
now you stay to the end of the video and
i didn't do
it [ __ ] outro are you kidding me i do
a proper outro
every video nobody stays to it and then
i do this [ __ ] and now you're still here
get the [ __ ] out